16 it is a monday morning and ladies and
gentlemen it is time to finally do what
we've been talking about for roughly a
few hours
it's time for the rose test as we head
towards valentine's day heather this
music makes me want to take one out and
put it in between my teeth right
okay so here's the deal though we are
not actually touching these at all we
ordered roses from five different flower
shops giving you kind of an idea of
what's going to be the best buy yes
before you you know plunk down all that
money on your sweetheart for valentine's
day so we don't actually know where they
came from
i mean there's five places we know the
five places we just don't know which one
belongs with which but it's a question
before as we head towards valentine's
day in a couple of weeks you know where
should we buy the flowers for our loved
ones uh where shouldn't we buy them what
will last the longest right we're trying
to help you plan ahead so again we don't
know where these are from you'll find
out right along with us here are the
five flower shops that we ordered from
there is the rose shack here in las
vegas
flowers of the field in henderson and
then one of these is from trader joe's
we also have 1 800 flowers
and proflower.com
so
we are not going to tell you which ones
are which like i said john and i don't
know only our boss does but we are going
to tell you how much they cost yes and
we're going to check in with them every
single morning to see
how well they're doing how do they look
right now what do you reckon this one's
hurting for certain a little bit those
ones are not so good
they're already a little wilty but this
this one right here this one's stunning
and it smells smells really good all
right follow along with us all week long
at six o'clock we'll have the rose test
as we head into valentine's day a little
fun for you on the good day las vegas
program a little bit of fun sherry
gorgeous roses have you smelled them yet
have not smelled them